hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel today I'm doing you know
the QA for hitting 90,000 subscribers
thank you guys so much it's insane that
we are actually getting close to a
hundred thousand but for those of you
who are here at ninety thousand I do
have a couple of tickets to a convention
that I'm going to next month to give
away at the end of this video if you
want to stay to check that out and also
sorry about the terrible quality again
I'm in a hotel room
III 2016 starts tomorrow so I'm in LA
last week I was in Canada okay let's get
to the questions simply an underscore
much hello on Instagram what would be
your ideal date scenario pizza and co-op
gala Seawatch 8 on instagram asks do you
do any PC gaming or just stick to
consoles
what about handhelds I love 3d out so
much there are so many amazing games on
that platform but haven't really tried
vita a whole lot i've just never really
had access to one as full pc i have
reviewed a couple of pc games full IGN
this you literally - and sometimes I
bring PCs home from work and I also have
access to any of the PCs that we have
that and I Jan's enormous steam library
so I still have access to PC games the
reason I don't personally own a PC is
just because I can't afford one people
always argue whenever I say that like I
should be able to afford it for some
reason but let me just pay you a pitcher
I live in the most expensive city in the
United States of America and all of my
family is in Australia so you know if
it's like a toss-up between ticket to
see my family or a PC when I already
have access to a lot of them ticket to
see my family is probably going to win
et bangin on Twitter there's one a
preface it's very funny that et Bang and
specifically asked this question however
have a one-night-stand becomes something
more I have never and will never have a
one-night stand
so no for geeks eyes only on Instagram
ass before you got into gaming what was
your thing and what was the game that
made you fall in love with gaming I was
very young when I started gaming I've
mentioned this on q and A's before but I
don't even remember when I started
gaming because it's something I've done
in my whole life I don't know which
specific game amy really get hooked into
games but it was definitely something on
the Nintendo 64 maybe banjo kazooie jet
force Gemini maybe even Mario caught I
always worry when people ask me a
question like this
like I always get asked Oh what got you
into gaming or when did you start gaming
feel free to correct me in the comments
if I'm wrong in this assumption but I
feel like I get asked that question a
whole lot more than any of my male
friends do and I kind of get the
impression that it's people waiting for
me to be like oh I have a brother or oh
my boyfriend or something like that
I don't know but I swear my guy friends
never get this question yeah man
double-oh-seven on twitter Oz oh you
ain't grill yes David pen run 60 fault
on Twitter ask who your favorite YouTube
is some people also ask what TV I
watched sure if I watch anime I pretty
much don't have time to consume any of
that kind of media so I don't watch
youtubers I don't watch twitch streams I
don't want you TV shows I don't watch
anime
I used to it's not that I don't like
that stuff I just don't have time to do
it anyway though there's definitely a
little pressure to keep up to date with
every single game that comes out which
means that all of my spare time goes to
what's playing games so that I can talk
about them adequately at work
rather than watching TV or youtubers or
anything else simply marchello Instagram
also awesome would you ever be
interested in acting in a movie slash TV
show um I actually have done a little
bit of acting I've done some short films
and I got costed a lead role from for a
TV show just before I moved to America
so obviously that got cancelled because
I couldn't be that for it it was
actually pretty excited about that
acting is something that I've always
liked since doing it in high school but
it's not something I've ever shared or
taken overly seriously joke is chaos on
Instagram moms do you ever think about
moving back home or has America won you
over yet
I think about being back home every
single day and I definitely wouldn't say
that America has won me over there's
things that I absolutely love about
America and things that exist in the US
that don't exist in Australia but
comparing the two countries isn't why
I'm here you know the reason that I'm in
America instead of Australia is because
I recognized that he industry that I am
in and the longtime Korea that I want is
bigger and there are more opportunities
for it in the u.s. see Brody on
Instagram asked what was your best
purchase in the last 12 months
probably coffee every day this season on
Instagram asked do you cook I cook a
batch of chicken breasts and I boil some
eggs for my milk prep every week but
other than that pretty much no I feel
like I'm kind of an outlier on this but
I find cooking insanely boring it's like
you put something in a pan and then you
just wait like god please let me do
anything else
what would we stick on Instagram Oz do
you do anything crazy in Montreal
why yes so I went to Montreal last
weekend to see watchdogs to my preview
of that is up on IGN if you want to
check it out I'll leave a link below
but I also DJed while I was there and
when I finished my set everyone was very
drunk and I literally breathes fire it
was like 180 percent alcohol it got in
my mouth but it looked very cool I hate
my name on Instagram ask if you're a
male in the Dragon Ball universe who
would you date okay what does being a
dude have to do with it I don't
understand
but Goku is one of my favorite
characters from anything ever
I adore Goku but he's also a terrible
husband and a very bad father so I don't
really think I'd want to date him
so her godless agenda my answer is
actually always going to be FOMA
G Biggles us do you like roosterteeth
have you ever heard of Blaine this is
actually the fourth roosterteeth related
question that I don't uh I know a few
people who work at roosterteeth and I
really like all of them
I met bunny at e3 last year he was a
really really nice guy I'm actually
think I'm going to be on a live stream
with him on Monday morning for the Xbox
conference promotional side note I'm
going to be on youtubes official
livestream of the Microsoft press
conference on Monday morning if you want
to watch that I think you just have to
go to youtube.com and it'll be on
Advanta somewhere saying it's live but
like in my previous answer I don't
really consume that kind of content but
I used to love red vs. blue and I arms
like one to seven on DVD I think also
Blaine is fine
Sam Christie on Twitter asked one of
three key things nobody realizes about
being a successful DJ you should ask a
successful DJ
I don't know GG Ozzy three one four on
Twitter us who was your favorite ninja
turtle and why my favorite ninja turtle
is definitely Donatello because he's the
smart one I also have a theory that you
can trust anyone who says Donatello is
the favorite ninja turtle you're all
good people they like you okay that is
it for the questions now it is giveaway
time I have two tickets to give away to
in haven Expo in Makai which is the expo
employments trailer for it is on July
2nd
it's a videogames pop culture convention
and I've been going for the past three
years or I think this is my third year
and it's awesome so if you're available
on July 2nd and you can get yourself to
Makai then hang out my Facebook page I
pinned the post to the top it's FB comm
/ charl on azad and I have competition
details there but yeah I can't wait to
hang out with people there it's gonna be
super fun so happy that I'm getting on
and thank you all again so much for 90
thousand subscribers you're all awesome
that is it for me today everyone I will
see y'all next time boy and also
hopefully next time we'll be not on a
webcam